this question kind of goes in the
opposite direction
so here we're expected to go from the
nice factorized form and then expand
here they give you an expansion and
they're expecting you to recognize well
what's the factorization
okay so you can see right there you've
got the coefficients that are right
one three three one right and in case
you couldn't recognize you have the
whole thing
cubed right so this is clearly i'm not
gonna use
x i'm gonna use something plus something
to the power of three
you just have to work out what the
pieces are okay now it's
convenient for you the very first term
is one okay so it's going to be
one plus something and then look at
these guys they're all the same
okay so here's the way i actually would
write it this is going to be 1 plus
something i'm going to call it u or q
directly recognize that from the
coefficients of the power
but to you know say i'm substituting
something i should say what the
substitution is equal to
so what's the thing that's being to the
power of one two three
it's x minus one right
that's all i have to do and so now i can
do some bigger brackets here
i can substitute in what i'm saying this
thing is equal to
one plus x minus one you just get an x
on the inside
that's rather easier than expanding the
whole thing okay
down here i'll do a bit of a shortcut
because you can see
what i'm doing in here you don't have to
do this step you can go straight to here
if you recognize it
right what's happening here what are my
two pieces
i'm going to have a one
and then watch out because i've got
signs happening here right negative
negative negative so instead of a one
plus
to a power it's going to be one minus
to a power right you've got the same
piece in here coming up again and again
and again that's
my my what i called u before x plus
one and we already know what the power
is going to be you just have a look at
the end
one minus x plus one that's
negative x right to power six and
because it's an even power
all of the negatives will cancel
happy so which one do you write as the
final one so the one the negative one
i i'd say that's simpler than that uh
even if i had if i had something like
this
minus x to the power of five i would
still prefer to write that as
negative x to the five uh this is a bit
of an awkward way of thinking about it
this has five negative signs in it and
this has one
so i think that's simpler